Just now let's look at a bunch
of different examples.
Here, basically doing a comparison to
conventional aperture corrections,
a conventional aperture like this
to use for doing corrections.
You see a little bit of ringing,
that's shown here.
You see a lot of defocusing, you can
see a little bit of ringing here also.
This is the output with this aperture,
much crisper image.
Here's an example very similar to what
we looked at when we did the light
fieldwork of being able to de-focus,
focus an image in a single image itself.
You can see basically,
interactively, we can focus one of,
one of the subjects and move around and
be able to focus on the other one.
Again, this is coded aperture.
We used to do these
types of captioning or
hold in, information on one image
to be able to allow you to do this.
Refocusing from a single
image in this example.
Hopefully, you can see this
on your compressed videos.
Now actually, I'm going to
borrow a specific example on
how these authors generated
this coded aperture.
That's it, they basically did was, open
up a lens, I don't recommend doing that
to your favorite high end
expensive lens by yourselves.
But open it up and
put that small aperture in there, and
then seal the camera back.
And of course when you put the camera
the lens back on the camera
you basically have a coded aperture.
Again, do this at your own peril.
I don't recommend taking off and
breaking up your very,
very favorite lens to
do this kind of stuff.